welcome to I've half tucked in my
t-shirt and that's considered a big day
for me no I'm gonna miss grace Ellie if
you didn't know now you know your life
is different now we're in the kitchen
it's been a second it's time for a
cooking video brought to you by the one
and only hellofresh
hello I cannot believe they still allow
me to do this the world is on fire how
about yours that's the way I like it
and that's not true at all smashmouth
the politicians of our generation
everything is a lot right now so I want
to do a fun dumb cooking video let's
just get right into this and have a
great time and all the other times
outside of this time you should be
educating yourself and participating and
speaking up and having uncomfortable
conversations right now the only
uncomfortable thing you have to do is
watch me what do I make it today
I had a great question sale never making
Middle Eastern chickpea balls okay
dibs I've forgotten how does do anything
other than look at Twitter and feel
overwhelmed here we go we're making
chickpea balls because I did it just
seems good and it's the last of the
meals from yellow French that I have
left and I didn't film any of the other
ones so this is we're doing it as always
somehow fresh all of your prepackaged
ingredients come in one handy dandy bag
no eggs and don't worry I actually
checked to make sure there were no eggs
in this recipe because I wasn't sure
what's in here so that's me being
responsible I know I say I don't know a
lot but lately it's time to actually
know and check and figure things out oh
talking points remember these kind of
things so you guys probably know about
how fresh by now and if you don't hi
where'd you come from what you been up
to and why are you here
hello fresh
meal delivery kit they mail you
prepackaged ingredients so you can make
delicious recipes they got something for
everyone they got low calorie they got
family friendly that's not right
do you imagine if they made like r-rated
meals it's just hot dogs and eggplants
yeah they do make family friendly it
does say family friendly I guess it's
like food that kids would like to use
this is move past this point you get it
they offer something for everyone
the meals average around 30 minutes so
you can get them done super quickly or
they have an extra quick option quick
and easy that's only 20 minutes on
average to make also by eating a little
fresh you're also eating slightly more
sustainably the packaging that their
food is shipped to you in is made of
almost entirely recyclable materials
that's something to feel good about in a
world where we're cousin bombarded by
feeling terrible about everything we're
having fun at least we're doing a lot of
work to make it seem like we are what's
the next one they're super flexible you
can change up your meal options you can
change your delivery dates you can add
some extra sides or some extra proteins
here and there they got all kinds of
stuff and this concludes the talking
points for now but let's just make the
damn thing oh look at all this cool fun
stuff yes we're gonna eat you with your
consent I forget how to do this a lot so
bear with me when the campers say to the
park ranger about a really needy
wildlife animal bear with me Wow
just bad like just bad every hello fresh
meal just has six steps which and very
should be super easy to do let's see
what happens
preheat the oven to 425 degrees that was
incredible I feel and cut the onion into
half-inch thick wedges
okay I'm looking at the instruction card
cuz I immediately forgot what I'm
supposed to do half feel cut I'm just
kind of chopping it big we're on this
beautiful onion then we're gonna peel
and mince our garlic am whoa very
cathartic equally cathartic roughly chop
the pistachios no smooth chops here
insert text joke I guess but you know
one that doesn't get misconstrued please
welcome to the stage miss construed a
roughly child you guys look like my
roots bro none of you are allowed to
self-actualize y'all gotta stay rap and
I want any of you getting a higher
education and what any of you you know
believing in your potential stay rough
brain and rinse the chickpeas boo the
main star of our meal chickpeas are not
problematic cuz chicks rule and pians
pretty cool then we pat them dry with
paper towels he eats me towel now I want
you to suck all the life out of each
other
roughly chop our cilantro you're getting
a rough chop too I don't want any of you
succeeding you look beautiful and put
together now know for doing the reverse
Eat Pray Love
you know what I've recently discovered
that is so obvious that I'm an idiot
is that you can use these brown bags
they give you as actually garbage bag as
you go blew my mind at how long it's
taking me to realize rough-chop our
cilantro
wow you guys do not look like you're
gonna get the promotion zest and quarter
the lemon stripping you of all of your
personality and we're done step one oh
okay now on the step two we're gonna
melt a tablespoon of butter in a small
pot over medium-high heat and then add
the minced onion half the garlic half
the pistachios half the swarm of spice
and a pinch of salt and then we cook
stirring for a minute minced onion oh we
have to mince a few of the wedges of
onion huh
so it seems I have done something wrong
already I was so confident in feeling
like I accomplished step one and you
know what I wasn't I did something wrong
and I know
hurt you it hurt me and my credibility I
just hope they'll be able to get that
trust back actions speak louder than
words
somebody's gonna keep talking stir for a
minute there we go
oh I slammed my finger in the drawer and
I told you that actions speak louder
than words in getting things right in
the kitchen and I clearly created an
action that shows I'm not meant to be a
role model in this situation but I'm
going to continue on the recipe starting
and I wasn't prepared for this I was
trying to joke around with you guys at
night look I'm glad that you're here but
I have to do okay then we stir in the
rice and 1/3 cup of water and the stock
concentrate 3/4 cup of water it's not
1/3 goddamn nice and you'd add the rice
and then the stock concentrate oh one
thing I don't got concentrate we bring
it to a boil and then we cover and we
reduce the heat to low and we let it
simmer for 15 to 18 minutes now we need
to toss our onion wedges tomatoes and
chickpeas on a baking sheet great job
guys you look beautiful so we're gonna
toss these with olive oil whoa look at
that it is like chef eating right now
the remaining schwarmann spice oh wow
beautiful pepper and salt hi yes I'm
going outside I'm not wearing a cooler
now we're gonna toss all of these
vegetables look at this party gonna
break up some of the onions you guys
need to interact with each other okay
you need to talk to each other you
probably have more in common than you
think and what you don't have in common
is interesting I know you might all be a
little scared to get to know each other
but just know that fear is excitement
and like a really tacky outfit okay now
we're gonna put these in the oven and
let this roast for 18 to 20 minutes and
now we're gonna wash our hands we're
gonna make our sauce get a little Bowl
oh oh this one's about to crack all the
way that's what people say after they
google my name feels nice sour cream in
bags just seems like
so vulnerable okay we are going to
combine our sour cream sour cream
he's always look like that huh we add
our remaining garlic and we season with
salt and we stirred a teaspoon of water
until we get it to a drizzling
consistency oh okay well with what
spilled on the floor it seems that it
has reached a drizzling consistency
watch this I'm a chef or I have a baby
either way I shouldn't have knives you
have another 15 minutes before
everything is done probably the amount
of time it takes to go have an
uncomfortable conversation with a racist
family member so I'm gonna let you do
that now see a little bit the rice
finished and then I put some butter half
the cilantro and some salt and pepper in
there and then I started eating another
snack because I haven't also got a lot
of a unhinge anxiety about everything so
I also don't want them to hear my
secrets paranoia is pretty trendy foods
done or my battery is actually
malfunctioning and this is the moment
where I become conscious that I have
been to West bald robot the whole time
vegetables look great they're all afraid
to hang out with each other and then
they all mixed and got along and made a
beautiful pile of delicious truly
probably the healthiest thing when me
putting in my body and haven't been for
the last two months let me move my
Scrabble game out of the way cuz it's
just staring me in the face I got lots
of stuff to get done today folks look at
these beautiful babies tossed with the
lemon zest look what happens
another diverse flavor profile joins the
party open sincere conversation mutual
respect passion for compassion now all
that's left to do is divide our rice and
make our Bowl look like the photo
I mean like this is pretty close this is
what a profile picture looks like and
then she shows up like this and you're
like wow maybe I should trust women look
at this what is beautiful thing that
looks great and edible this is exactly
what I want I know exactly what you want
probably a discount on have a fresh
after experiencing how easy and
effortless and efficient it is to do for
yourself at home well I got you covered
you go to hell oho calm and use the
promo code really big sixty you will get
sixty dollars off your first three weeks
of food including free shipping on your
first box with purchase again go to
harrys.com use the promo code gray 0-60
get sixty dollars off your first three
weeks of food including free shipping on
your first box with purchase also this
should make you feel really good
television gives back they donated 2.5
million meals last year to charity 2019
two point five million meals and this
year they're doing even more though
evening eating is the left to do part of
this video here we go let's try this oh
yeah I'm super into this when
ingredients from all different areas of
a grocery store come together and make
something so harmoniously peacefully
delicious ah the power it has well
that's it I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did give it a thumbs up
thank you for watching let me know in
the comments down below with how are you
what's going on what's you up to yeah
cool how do you end videos again good
boy subscribe if you want to other than
that I don't know stay off Twitter wear
a mask black lives matter trans rights
or human rights
get registered to vote is it simple to
do this really easy when you try yes
what have you been up to just looking
like a freak vote I'm cool